i started listening to your book about
four or five days ago and the very first
chapter talks about this idea of me plus
yeah um i wonder if you're gonna like
elaborate like what does what does me
plus mean
so if you i mean if you go back to the
economics we're really good i think at
making at helping ourselves in the
present day so we know what makes us
happy in the moment but very often the
things that we have to invest in to give
our future selves a better future we
don't often do so what i like people to
do is to think about where would they
like to be if it all worked out so if
they threw out you know lost aversion if
they threw out fear of failure where
will they actually end up being and have
that be their me plus but before they
commit to that being their me plus
really think about what will that me
plus actually do because i've noticed a
lot of times when i talk to people about
careers they're attached to a label so
they want to be a trader or an
investment banker or they want to be a
doctor
or they're attached to a lifestyle so
they want to be able to go on a
particular vacation or buy a particular
car and kind of think big journey is
really thinking about if i were to be a
doctor if i were to be a trader what
would be the tasks that i would be doing
on a day-to-day basis and would i
ultimately end up enjoying those tasks
so the activities that i'm going to
spend the time in
and there's two reasons for that so one
it makes you happier to actually do
tasks that you like which feels like a
no-brainer but secondly if you're
engaged in tasks that you like you tend
to be more successful and it's the
second that i'm really interested in and
kind of getting people into jobs where
they feel that they've reached the
success that they want okay
interesting and do you think
when it comes to being engaged in tasks
that you like some people say it's a
case of find the thing that fits within
your values your personality and when
once you find that thing then you'll
find it fun and then there's another
school of thought that says well you
know the whole finding something that
you're passionate about is actually kind
of hard to do so think about the stuff
that you're actually doing and find ways
to make it more interesting for yourself
uh how how do you feel about those two
different different camps i don't really
feel that they're different so you know
so so people are claiming now that they
choose companies based on the values the
companies might have
and i think that's true in the same way
that we choose a company based on a
salary but when you're actually in the
job what tends to matter with respect to
productivity and happiness is how you
feel in those tasks in that moment and
if i'm working for a company that's
saving the environment but i've been
treated really badly in a microculture
in order to save that environment
there's a couple of companies come to
mind when i think about that um then i'm
not going to be productive and i'm not
going to be happy i'm actually likely to
leave that that job so it's more about
going beyond thinking what is the
company's mission what is my personality
and what is the micro culture of the
team that i'm going to be working in and
will that make me happy will i be
connected to the mission because my team
is connected to the mission
it's very hard to assess in advance when
you're applying for a job it's really
hard it is it's really really hard and i
think then if you bring it down to the
tasks and asking at an interview what
will i be doing on a day-to-day basis
um so when i come to work for you ali
what would i be doing on a day-to-day
basis as part of your team um so if you
can imagine me on a monday how will i
spend my time
the fact that you as a manager have
taught about that first they will tell
me that you're a good manager because
you'll know actually what you want the
person to do um and you're not just
hiring blindly but the second is having
that information allows me to make my
mind up because if the if i like the
tasks i'm probably going to like the
team okay yeah that's very interesting
so that was a big part of the message i
took away from the me pluster and the
way it it manifested in my life when i
read it i was i was thinking okay you
know let's engage with this like what's
what's kind of what does me plus look
like and initially i was thinking oh you
know i'd really like to have six-pack
abs and then i came across a bit where
you were like i don't know forget about
that focus on like what what did the
tasks look like and i was like okay you
know what what i want me plus to do is
to be able to exercise every day and to
have fun doing it yeah um and so for the
last four days i've actually been to the
gym i went to a yoga class yesterday
morning i did a workout at like eight
a.m this morning and i i've never really
done this sort of thing but i was like
excited about that
i i was excited that the end goal was
not six six-pack abs i was excited that
the end goal was that in a way there
wasn't an end goal and it was a case of
just i want to be able to enjoy this um
is that the sort of thing that you get a
lot when you're doing this sort of
research that process rather than
outcome kind of thing so i kind of write
a lot for kind of people who might have
made it yes or people who have plateaued
so if you take the exercising analogy
from somebody who's contemplating doing
the kind of a 5k run rather than
somebody who is contemplating doing the
london marathon and is really well
placed for that
and i think for the person who hasn't
done exercise for a while or the person
who hasn't really invested in their
career for a while the worst thing they
can do is do too much so if you hadn't
invested for a while the worst thing you
could do is go to the gym for three
hours you might get through it today but
the chances of repeating that are really
really small and i think kind of the one
of the big powerful messages underline
anything big is whether you're focused
on your health or whether you're focused
on your career it's those small actions
that you take today will determine
yourself in two years time three years
time in four years time and actually by
throwing out the idea that you're going
to reinvent yourself in 30 days is
really really powerful because you're
much more likely to stick to it you know
you can accomplish an extraordinary
amount in 12 months very little in you
know 12 minutes or you know a very short
period of time you know i've been making
videos semi-themed around productivity
for the last four years and a big chunk
of the advice boils down to
consistency and just showing up and
taking small actions repeatedly and in a
way not really worrying so much about
the ultimate goal um and these days i
teach i uh teach courses helping people
become like youtubers and stuff and and
the way you become a successful youtuber
is you just make one or two videos every
week for the next like five years um but
no one sticks to it for that long
because they have like the oh i must hit
a certain subscriber count i must hear a
certain like view count and
my view on this is that having like in a
way those outcome metrics the ones that
are outside of our control are kind of
unhelpful especially at the start of a
journey do you have any thoughts on on
that point well when you were talking it
actually reminded me i watched a video
of yours on compounding so when people
are choosing to invest
we accept compounding very very easily
right so we accept the idea actually
that you know if we leave money in for a
very long period of time it's going to
compound so we're probably going to be
okay in our pensions and it's exactly
the same here when it comes to your
career like those very small things that
you're going to do today and i ask for a
commitment of 90 minutes a week which
for most people regardless of how
pressurized you feel is very very
possible um that should compound once
you do once you've chosen tasks that
align with your me plus relatively
quickly okay 90 minutes a week that's
like 13 minutes a day-ish yes very
doable